a sociopath what does it mean
and why is everyone talking about it
sociopath
is boiled down someone who is
just more savage thank you for the
clarification logan
very cool a sociopath it's just someone
a more savage everyone now this topic is
being
widely discussed on youtube thanks to
shane dawson's latest video
the dark side of jake paul it's got 15
million views and
it was number one on trending for a
while now shane talks about sociopath
in this series and tries to answer the
question
is jake paul a sociopath now
this video rubbed me the wrong way and a
lot of other people
and here is why to be clear when shane
announced that he was going to make
a video series on jake paul i thought
wow that's actually really interesting
because shayna usually digs deeper with
his topics and he actually interviews
people so
to uncover more information like the
tanacon thing
he actually interviewed tana so yeah i
was really excited about it until he
said it was going to be an
eight-part series eight parts why
how can you make an eight-part series on
jake paul and watching the latest video
you realize
it's because it's not about jake paul
this video called
the dark side of jake paul has hardly
anything to do with jake paul
it's a 45 minute sit down with this
therapist
talking about sociopath and sort of
alluding to
jake being one which is kind of a
sociopathic thing to do
if you ask me i don't know trying to
reach
that someone might be a sociopath
without having to met them
i don't know it's kind of weird now
watching through this video you realize
jake is 100 a sociopath shane is a
sociopath i'm a sociopath
you're a sociopath everyone is a
sociopath because the definition of what
a sociopath is
was so incl incredibly vague that
uh it fits anyone for example they drive
fast probably
they drive fast have you ever driven
fast so do you play
things that harm usually yeah yeah
tattoos
probably
so anyway guys i know these are just
examples but
there were so many of them uh my
favorite my favorite is this one i gotta
meet a giraffe
weirdo i mean this
picture that looks like too [ __ ]
straight-up sociopaths planning
their next move
oh the caption let's go
the caption is he joking i don't
understand
it was before the boxing fight like he
put a caption let's go
he's a sociopath they also had uh
another one that was really good uh
for instance the other day i was in my
car and i'm driving there's this little
lady that started to get into the
crosswalk and i was like honey you got
like 12 seconds
i'm worried i hope people wait for you
and like pay attention
right you know a sociopath would just be
like
ugh like i wouldn't even i wouldn't
worry there's no worry for her
you ever scoffed at an old lady being
slow i got bad news for you
then they dropped the big number the big
whole
the whole thing with the video i think
that a lot of people latched on to
uh and for a video with this many views
it's kind of annoying how this is
what's going to be spread around from
now on probably from a lot of people
how realistic is it for me to know one
they say one in 25.
that was like one end so shane asked how
many people
are sociopaths and and she says 1 in 25
now the source i could find for this was
from author mother stout
who says that 1 in 25 americans secretly
has no conscience
and can't do anything at all without
feeling guilty
called the sociopath next door now this
is clearly put on the front of a book
to sell more books it's a it's on the
cover
to intrigue people to sell more because
it sounds interesting
now what i found was that three percent
of males
and one percent of females have apd
anti-personality disorder and this is
mentioned in the video
but just because you have
anti-personality disorder does not make
you
a sociopath i understand what shane is
trying to do is to draw more people in
and make this more interesting
uh painting this picture that anyone can
be a sociopath and anyone can be
you know you never know uh which makes
it more interesting i get it
but when you're talking about mental
health you kind of have to be more
responsible than that the video
constantly uses
this bizarre stock footage edits in them
with this creepy background music well
there's a bar right there here like if
we walk into that bar there's probably
100 people
so that means there's four why isn't
that it's like talked about
jesus is that a fake reaction enough for
you
they didn't talk about logan paul's
famous forest video to me it was like
oh this is sad i'll put a sad song so
not saying he's a sociopath but like
that's something that a sociopath would
do right
like totally yeah if somebody didn't
know like how to be emotionally they
would just go to the audio library and
like literally click the emotions
pick the emotion that they want people
to feel do they not know
like would they if okay if a youtuber is
a sociopath and they're making an
apology video
i first want to apologize to my brother
so they just type in sav and they pick
one so like they just like google
emotions and like
put them in the video uh you do the same
thing
everyone does this if you need a sad
song you search for sad music
so you can find the sad song just like
in the sad part of your video you added
sad music
or multiple yeah so then it's like that
person is never going to experience like
the joy of like
having sex for the first time or like
getting your first car
like going to new music they don't like
and i don't know maybe it's just me but
i think
adding creepy music while talking with
the therapist about mental health
is kind of a sociopathic thing as well
now shane's response to this
was the reason i made it scary and
creepy
was so people would watch it because if
i made it
like a standard video where i just sat
there and was like oh interesting they
don't feel okay
next topic people wouldn't care and i
disagree
but then again i don't get 15 million
views of my videos
i just think in some topics you either
do them right
or you just don't touch them the video
is called the dark side of jake paul
people are gonna watch it regardless i'm
pretty sure
and it didn't even have anything to do
with jake or hardly anything
when it comes to this type of person or
when it comes to this disorder you don't
want to xyz
you even think about that i mean you
don't the video uses the
clips of randomly of youtubers while
talking about
this whole thing you know not just jake
paul but
others as well and if you have to be
kind of a sociopath to be a youtuber
honestly are you a sociopath uh
i don't know we all know david's a
psychopath
y'all exactly i'm also not a sociopath
or have some type of
you know personality and not until 11
minutes and 30 seconds in the video you
get this disclaimer
all clips shown on youtubers actors and
even myself are just being used for
context
or 100 percent not insinuated that any
people showing ourselves about
usually you add these at the beginning
of the video but uh
i don't know that's just what i think i
like i i don't know it just made me
laugh out loud like after
dragging all these youtubers by the way
guys uh
not insinuating anything my favorite one
however
is this one they're mimicking they're
honing their craft kind of
so if they're not very good at it
they won't elicit the right response out
of you her fans are not having it
because they once again just a clip for
context
it has nothing to do with what we're
saying we're not attacking this person
just for context just for context
just for context clips as well was used
with
actual killers actual murderers like o.j
simpson and i don't know who this is but
will you kill again
if the opportunity arises i hope so
so it's kind of blurring the line
between not just youtubers but also
sociopath
and killers as well just because you're
a sociopath
doesn't mean you're a killer or that you
want to hurt people and this was sort of
sort of reinforced by the therapist as
well in the video talking about
impulsivity and that
that can lead you to become more
dangerous which is what makes them a
little dangerous i always think
impulsive is like a dangerous thing
for both them and the people around them
you know when
a simple google will tell you the
opposite well it's common to think
sociopaths and psychopaths are
inherently dangerous this is more a
construct of tv drama
than a true reflection of the disorder
it is definitely possible
but it's not an inherent characteristic
and shane is doing the same thing here
sort of overly dramaticizing the topic
for the sake of drawing people in so
your only regret is that the torture
didn't go on anything
right and i regret not killing my other
victim
the weirdest thing about the video is
that the therapist they're referring to
really icky or really
nasty or gross behavior i'm feeling sick
it's really gross and it's just creepy i
literally my heart really gross i know
isn't that kind of weird for a therapist
to do i don't know i understand not
liking it
i don't either but for a therapist to
describe uh mental disorder as
really icky really gross i don't know
that's kind of weird to me
now the cherry on the top uh after this
video you know
has described everyone as a soto pant
basically anyone falls into this
category
uh it's also sponsored by
better health today's episode is brought
to you by betterhelp this is something i
really think is great and something i
actually
really believe in you're a sociopath by
the way this video is sponsored by
online therapy also this video
enter the coupon code shane for your
online therapy today
by the way guys everyone is a sociopath
enter the code
shane for your cheaper online therapy
today
now this is one of those online therapy
apps they've becoming more and more
popular
a lot of people have said they work
great for them but they also get
a lot of bad reviews saying that they
don't work at
all and if they work for you great but
it's kind of questionable to promote one
of these
services i did i think uh a year ago
and they asked me to talk about that and
i'm like okay fine
but i would never want to take money
from it i would never want to
take money for a mental health app it
just doesn't feel
right and i'm probably the most morally
skewed person ever
so for me to come up with that
conclusion and not shane it's kind of
weird now
after all this there was a bit of
backlash
i mean it has a million likes and thirty
thousand dislikes that's
that's hardly anything i think most
people just enjoy the video and i think
that's fine
uh but shane did make an apology where
he said
i'm sorry if i offended anybody
oh no no oh no no no no no
shane uh this is not it okay i'm sorry
if i offended anyone
said in lengthy snapchat video shane if
you need help with apology videos
just reach out i'm really good at them
this is a big no-no
number one i'm sorry if i offended
anybody if you are offended for someone
i'm sorry you were offended i know he
doesn't mean it like that it's just
bad badly worded um the therapist made a
response as well
hey everybody i find myself getting
bullied in comments and i know i've
opened myself to a whole another group
of people
and that's fine and i'm an adult and
like if i have to block you that's what
i'm gonna do because i don't have to
allow you
to hang out in my pool great response
these are great responses guys just
please just come to me all right
if you need help with apologies i'll set
you up this
ain't it they say you're making it worse
we had like five hours of footage so i
really cut it down um and try to make it
entertaining which
is my fault i should have maybe just
left it very
clean i wanted to make it entertaining
but but at the
at the core of it what i wanted people
to know is like
an actual sociopath does not care
is it okay to dehumanize someone just
because they don't care if you do
i don't really agree with that i think
shane made a mistake
of starting off this series asking if is
jake paul a sociopath
it's either yes or no and and you know
maybe to the benefit of the doubt maybe
he uncovers something
that we don't know about jake that
hasn't been told before
there's a lot more episodes coming up to
this series so
to remain optimistic that could be the
case
uh i don't know if jake is a sociopath
because i'm not a psychologist
and i can't evaluate him
but a lot of these topics are gray areas
while we like to say that someone either
yes or no is a sociopath
most of the time that that's not the
case
and uh funny enough logan reached out
and made a video
talking about just this starting off
with the classic
lasai dear shane dawson
how to start a heavy topic you gotta say
it out 99
of the time someone is not a sociopath
or not a sociopath my opinion is there's
a sociopathic
spectrum at which point some people lie
higher on it than others and by the way
some of the biggest businessmen in the
world could be considered
sociopathic uh mark jobs
steve zuckerberg logan actually makes a
lot of sense here how about that
i never thought i'd say that then again
he also did say
uh original point what i'm trying to say
is she
you you
are scaring your young and interminable
you are scaring your young
impressionable audience logan paul
everybody
logan paul the least self-aware human
being on the planet
shane dawson how dare you scare these
children now logan for
that a hundredth time so many people
told me
before their famous forest video oh
logan he's like the cool one of the
pulse he's like
the the nice one the less crazy one and
i always said nah
nah that ain't it he's a real crazy one
and then the fourth video came out and
i'm like i told you
i freaking told you i was even quick to
point out like
logan paul is a sociopath because if you
look at youtube
it's a shame because it's such an
interesting topic this whole thing is an
interesting topic and now it's just gone
completely
gotten completely mixed up uh i think
the line between youtubers and
sociopaths is really interesting
because if you look at youtube it sort
of rewards
sociopathic behavior and i think that's
why it's so easy for me for example to
spot it in
other youtubers while for a lot of other
people who are not aware of it
it will just go unnoticed for example
you understand as a youtuber
what kind of thought process went
through a person's mind
or a youtuber's mind when they made a
thumbnail
uh what they want to present in it what
was important for them for other people
to know or
how they present a message and a topic
how they present it in what tone and
like they said with the music or
whatever most people don't think about
these things but as a youtuber you
realize and
you think and you understand what went
through their head to make this decision
and you realize wow they're actually
kind of messed up
and youtube in a way rewards these
things you you don't get more views for
having integrity
that's for sure and i think that's the
thing with jake and logan they
they just don't care they're just
extremely
goal oriented and motivated to to become
popular on youtube and earn money
that's what they want they're not trying
to hide that it's pretty obvious
they'll do whatever they can to get that
does that mean their sociopath
i don't know maybe but it certainly
100 make some scumbags maybe they have
some other personality behind the scenes
maybe
they're actually really cool in person
maybe really chill but then again we've
seen their action online
does it really matter you wouldn't go to
a killer and be like well
maybe he's actually like a really nice
person
that's a bad example but you understand
what i mean i think what went wrong with
this whole
video the whole shane video and why i
think it's so bad is because
apparently shane didn't tell katie i
think that's her name the therapist
that this was about jake paul
well i'll explain later what this all is
there's a lot more to it than yikes
apparently
shane i i think he mentioned in the
video that he didn't tell her that
originally that this was going to be
about jake paul they were just going to
sit down and talk about sociopaths
and you know she's referring a lot of
times in this video
uh about anti-personality disorder but
through editing and the creepy music and
all that it kind of conflicts and
it becomes anything it becomes it gets
mixed up with killers and all kinds of
stuff
uh and i don't know if that's
necessarily her fault as well
and i understand shane wants to make
things creepy that's what he does he
makes these conspiracy
videos um that's how he keeps things
interesting
and i can understand that and i can
respect that he does a great job of that
and i also think katie
took off her therapist hat to sort of
drop these numbers and facts just to
make it more interesting because she
knows that's what shane wanted
kind of like how neil degrasse tyson
drops these science bombs
to blow your mind it's the same kind of
thing and
maybe it wasn't deliberate but these two
things playing into each other just
made it into in my opinion a really bad
video
unfortunately some topics you just have
to be more careful
when you cover them and maybe not add in
creepy music and all these
uh stupid things in the background i
think they realize that now
uh that's it however for my eight-part
series about
shane dawson hope you guys are looking
forward to this
actually i might make it a 20 part
series i think we can really uncover
some deeper darker secrets in here
smash like if you enjoyed this video let
me know what you guys think
are you just jealous because shane gets
more views than you